not belong to the S and D group and as
of the 11th of May 2023 she will belong
to the PPE
the next item on the agenda is the
European citizens initiative stop
thinning stop the trade
on behalf
of the reporters
must Cook Out
on behalf for two minutes
evening everyone on this lovely Thursday
morning uh first of all I really would
like to congratulate the the people that
took the initiative of these European
citizens initiative on stop Finning stop
the trade within two years having more
than 1.1 million signatures from all the
27 member states so this is to us really
a key example of a very successful
European citizens initiative which then
also should be taken seriously and
should get a follow-up and that's of
course the point of the discussion also
today just on the matter we know already
that it is forbidden to remove fins on
Boards of ships and also to uh to trade
them so we need to bring them on lands
in an entire form but we also know that
still the EU remains a huge hub for
shark fins and it's a made in export and
Transit Center for Asia and relatively
speaking the role of Europe is getting
bigger because global trade is going
down and the European all remains
comparable and with that relatively
speaking our role becomes bigger and
that is undeniable I know sometimes
industry tries to deny the facts which
you cannot do
this also of course relates very much
back to the discussion we had yesterday
on restoration law when we are talking
about restoring nature and restoring our
ecosystem sharks are crucial for our
marine ecosystems so we do want to see
action from the commission
the charts are protected on the
societies and also last year in Panama
more shark species were added to the
appendix to list of societies showing
that now more or less 90 percent of the
traded shark and race species are
falling on the sites which shows that we
have serious concerns with sharks
so it's an endangered species the
practices are cruel so let's act on it
and that's also the very clear demand
from the citizens and this is also then
the very clear question to the
commission you will probably say nice
words about the initiative but we want
to hear concretely what is the
commission going to do with this demand
from our citizens thank you very much
thank you very much Mr Christensen from
the Fisheries committee
yes good morning
it pleases me to be able to
start this debate about the European
citizens initiative stop filling stop
the trade
around 1 million people have signed the
initiative and we have to take that
seriously as parliamentarians that so
many people want a visible debate it's
about democracy
and this is why this debate is very
important
Sharks play an important role in the
ecosystems
since the mid-80s
there's been a big fishing pressure on
sharks
and big demand for shark fins especially
in the Asian markets
for more than 20 years it has been
prohibited to cut off shark fins in the
E Waters and from EU vessels
and it looks completely crazy
that in other parts of the world they
cut off the shark fins and throw the
rest of the body into the water that's
unethical especially since the species
threatened
we have to preserve the shark's pieces
sustainably
and we also need to
we also need to prohibit the trade of
shark fins and the trend shipment and
import and exports of
shark fins
I was part of the initiative the one
taking the initiative for that in the
Fisheries committee
we hope for Action from the commission
before July of this year
this debate is a good opportunity to
exchange points of views about this
issue
thanks to all for taking part in this
Democratic process about such a serious
issue
the uh
I give the floor to the commissioner
good morning honorable president
honorable members the European citizens
initiative that we are discussing today
rightly points to boring situation of
sharks globally and to the role that
demand for shark fins in Asia place in
this and we share these concerns of
citizens and therefore we are active
both within and outside the European
Union when it comes to protecting sharks
and promoting sustainable fishing in
view of international dimension of the
shark fin strength it is important to
ensure adequate rules within the EU and
internationally the EU actively promotes
the conservation and sustainable
management of sharks as well as the fins
naturally attached policy in regional
fisheries management organizations and
in other relevant International forum
the practice of shark filling is already
banned in all regional fisheries
management organizations
some shark species need protection
through a retention ban lists other
species can still be fished sustainably
through appropriate conservation and
management measures and those
conservation and management measures may
include a limited total allowable catch
since 2008 EU law and namely the Marine
strategy framework recreative requires
that shark populations in our waters are
healthy and abundant and that human
activities do not harm them
and with the nature restoration law
proposal we continue our efforts by
seeking the restoration of the habitats
of shark and race pieces the EU also
works actively under two International
conventions to protect sharks firstly
the EU is a signatory of the memorandum
of understanding of the conservation of
migratory sharks which concerns research
sustainable fishing habitat protection
and international cooperation secondly
the EU is an active member of the
convention of international trade in
endangered species of wild fauna and
Flora scientists which among others
regulated trade of sharks and their
products so the EU promote scientist
protection for marine species and
incorporates its decision in its own
legal setup including trade restrictions
for Relevant species given this solid
International framework sharks caught by
the eufleet in compliance with both
scientists and regional fisheries
management organizations rules are
considered as legitimate fish products
at EU level since 2003 the so-called EU
shark-finning regulation prohibits the
removal of shark fins on board of all
vessels in the waters as well as the
retention onboard transshipment or
Landing of shark fins in 2000 in 2013
the regulation was amended to enforce
Finn's naturally attached policy So
currently all sharks targeted by
commercial fishing must be retained on
board and must be landed with their fins
naturally attached and there are no
derogations from this obligation the
fins can be removed only upon Landing
this applies to EU fishing vessels
wherever they operate even Beyond EU
Waters honorable members this was a
short outline of what we already doing
both within and outside the European
Union to protect the tax and to promote
sustainable fishing and I have already
had privilege to meet twice with
organizers of this citizens initiative
once during the dedicated meeting with
the commission and a second time in the
European Parliament hearing both
encounters and discussions where a
welcome opportunity to better understand
the objectives of the initiatives and to
discuss possible further actions to
reinforce the EU policy on the
protection of shocks against this
background the commission is currently
preparing the reply to the European
citizens initiative stop filling stop
the trade which it will adopt by July
2023 in line with the provisions of the
ECI regulation thank you
thank you very much we would now
appreciate with the speakers from the
political groups Mr Mato from the PPE
well thank you very much I'm very
pleased to see we have a session
dedicated to Fisheries this morning
yesterday the fishes around Europe
um rejected to the policy being
implemented by the EU we need to revise
uh the policy and with this ESI we need
to recognize the fact that in Europe we
are setting example uh for the world we
have a solid uh policy which allows for
the exploitation which is not in the
situation other countries now this
includes thinning for our European
operators we have policies that are from
2013 and when it says that fins must be
naturally attached and has to be
observers on board as well there's a
certain a vulnerable species which which
can't be a court and certain species
have been banned for decades now in
accordance with societies this means
that the the trade of shark fins is
regulated and limited and
sharks can now only be
um traded if they are not in dangers so
um
those fins which are traded from Europe
are
um uh are done under the correct
um regulation and they all need to be um
completed with the necessary Society
certificate as well which uh assess out
our origin and uh and traceability if we
try and close this then all we will be
doing it would be pushing this trade
outside of the EU where the fishing of a
shark is much more sustainable than in
the EU we in the EU only a small
percentage of global trade in shark fins
moreover the band would not address the
major threat for sharks which is uh
overfishing in an unsustainable manner
this ban will only uh penalize the
sustainable operators of the EU and
countries such as China and Korea which
have blocked any Global initiative to
stop
the feeling in international Forum will
continue with the international practice
with their with their practice is that
what we really want that's if
thank you very much and now Mr Matic
from the snd group for two minutes
thank you
Mr President
commissioner the protection of sharks
and our oceans is an important topic for
many Europeans and every year more than
100 million sharks are killed mainly for
their fins their fins are mostly
important and consumed in Hong Kong
Singapore and Taiwan 45 of them comes
from the European Union and this number
is on the increase
and not only the Finns have no
nutritional values but they are not
tasty and they are harmful for our
health and it is also they are also very
dangerous because uh because of high
levels of mercury Arsenic and other
poisonous Metals so we're talking uh um
exclusively about the profits of those
implementing this practice legal market
for Fins of sharks opens areas for the
market of illegal fins because it is
really difficult to identify their
origin it is really difficult to
identify the fins that were detached
from the shark because you can only use
a DNA test but this is very rare because
it is very costly
numerous agreements on fins trades and
sharks have been signed throughout the
world but the European Union is still
passive about it
the European Union undertook the
commitments during the recent ocean
conference in Panama and it showed that
it is ready to take the leading role in
protecting the oceans unfortunately more
has to be done the main issue is how to
turn all these promises into concrete
actions the new regulations on
restoration of nature was an opportunity
to protect the maritime habitats but
unfortunate this didn't go through
because many other
um
uh
many other
parties did not support this idea
one million signatures have signed these
initiatives and they remind us that this
is an important problem what else needs
to happen in order for us to understand
that the future of the fishery sector
food security and degenerational
restoration depend on an overall
protection of our endangered species and
habitants
today we're talking about sharks
thank you for two minutes
for a good morning thank you
commissioner we do not agree with the
content of this European citizens
initiative because the European Fleet as
stated in a scientific report prior to
revision of the 605 2013 regulation
states that the Europe does not practice
Finning our uh uh vessels need to land
the um shock with the fins naturally
attached since November in fact any uh
thing that is
um
exported has to include ascites document
now this document is a result of the
international
trade international conventions in this
area so this says quite clearly that to
the the film which is attached to this
the shark is is being landed in Legally
so the initiative does not bring
anything new for the sustainability of
the European Fleet however on the
contrary it brings new restrictions for
either professionals in the sector and
would lead to high levels of pressure on
the species
when a flight fleets in other parts of
the world are not subjected to these so
China or or Korea will continue to put
to block
um the new measures in our f um O's and
they'll continue to be clandestine
transshipment in the high seas the
solution as a result means that we need
to strengthen the external element to
the common Fisheries policies one of the
missions of the CSP is to extend uh
Norms around the world
we'd also like to know what problems
does the commission find in the rfmo so
that these norms and standards are not
being assumed by countries around the
world that do practice Finning and these
cosmetic citizens initiatives would just
undermine the most sustainable Fleet in
the world and the actual species that
we're trying to protect thank you very
much and now Miss Rose for one minute on
behalf of the greens group
thank you president commissioner Finning
is a cruel practice of cutting off the
fins from live sharks and has been
banned in EU since 2013 and yet the EU
is still one of the largest exporters of
shark fins in the world
we go on killing very large numbers of
sharks to feed the fin trade
scorning the consequences for
biodiversity a million
plus European citizens have signed the
European citizens initiative calling for
a ban on the trade in shark fins
this ban is needed the fact there's
still a legal shark fin trade
facilitates a laundering of illegal fins
which is the fins that come from
thinning of protected species
Banning the shark fin trade would make
it easier to combat the illegal trade in
protected species and would enable a
reduction in a number of shark killed
every year
to stop the Mass Slaughter of elephants
we banned the ivory trade to save the
shark we must ban the trade in their
fins so thank you commissioner millions
of citizens are counting on you
thank you
and now
Mr rookmaker on behalf from the is Mrs
brookmaker corrects himself the
president contracts himself from the ECR
group
foreign
Europe needs more direct democracy
democracy of
Europe the democracy
the Democracy for
a democracy is the Cornerstone of Europe
it is the best form of government and it
is the basis for peaceful coexistence
but democracy is under pressure
worldwide even here in Europe the
greatest pressure is not coming from the
right or from the left the greatest
threat for democracy are vested
interests because when you have power it
is difficult to share power political
parties are an instrument of power
sometimes there are a link between
voters and lawmakers but sometimes they
are an unintended obstacle to what
Burger their citizens want to see thanks
to the citizens initiative that has been
assigned by 1.1 million people the
commission is going to protect life and
and they did that over over a thousand
citizens
have expressed their Wills or shark
Finning they want this uh to stop and
political parties must recognize this
and the commission knows what the
position of the parliament is we need to
listen better
um
so that we can live together and then we
need to act for a democratic Europe and
a peaceful future thank you
thank you from the ID group of Miss
Bruno for one minute
thank you president Finning as mentioned
before me is cutting the fin from the
live shark before throwing its body back
into the sea which is a barbaric
practice which is not part of our morals
and Customs which is why we banned it in
2013 in the EU but the EU is still one
of the biggest exporters of shark fins
the European commission once again
is showing that it's very permissive
with this drift into industrial fishes
uh put whilst inflicting unbearable
standards on our own fissures this
undermines our food security and
Industrial ships end up exporting these
fins to Asia the commission must
activate this cruel illegal fishing
which is harmful for the ecosystem
accepting these practices makes us an
accomplice in this so thank you for the
commissioner for the decision to ban
this trade that you'll take
very strong
thank you very much next speaker on
behalf of the left Ms hazakamp for one
minute
thank you very much president welcome
commission
um sharks have an important role in the
underwater world every year over a
million sharks are hunted and killed for
their fins and uh uh uh fishermen even
in Europe are um part of this attack on
live shows it's an illegal practice
whereby uh the fins are cut off living
shocks and then the animals are thrown
helpless back into the sea and uh this
uh hunting of sharks means that are now
167 species are threatened with
Extinction 1.1 million citizens assigned
an initiative to stop the trade and this
horrific hunt but under pressure from
the fishing Lobby the parliament is
refusing to take auction we call on the
commission to take
um
action and to stand up for the
protection of sharks World War and
furthermore I think that European
agriculture and fishing subsidies should
be eliminated
thank you the speakers on behalf of the
political groups have is finished and
now we proceed president
commissioner
ladies and gentlemen
Hayes
trade in the desirable fins is booming
even though their consumption is
unadvisable because of high Mercury
content it is precisely the EU that has
an ever increasing share in this deathly
trade EU member states like Spain
Portugal and France belong to the
leading shark fishing countries
biodiversity and the functioning of the
Marine ecosystem are in great Danger
will the EU live up to its International
commitments if so it has no choice but
to ban completely the trade in shark
fins over 1.1 million EU citizens
standing up for that idea and I speak on
behalf of those 1.1 million European
citizens today stop Finning stop the
trade
thank you very much and now
Mr polcheck has the floor for one and a
half minutes
thank you Mr President this European
citizens initiative uh aims to stop by
the trade with uh fins in Europe
citizens uh required that the EU
regulation be extended to uh the trade
with uh fins and also uh request that uh
another
regulation be extended around 270 a
million um
are actually killed throughout the world
this is a huge number but maybe the
actual uh figure is much higher the uh
Chief consumers of fins are in Asia even
uh but but European countries are among
the biggest Traders
and fishes for uh Finn's uh the
inspections at seas are very uh scarce
they should be more frequent and more
coordinated between the member states it
there is no doubt that we have
a responsibility for biodiversity and we
should set out the rules that will rule
out any uh thinning
and definite however I am not in favor
of banning uh the trade with but what if
system
the
um
thank you president commissioner firstly
I'd like to congratulate those who have
brought this citizens initiative forward
any initiative means we have citizen
participation that's good for European
democracy however I think it's pointing
in the wrong direction here in Europe we
live in a society where we have rules
which says that it was sharpening is
illegal so I think the European Union is
quite advanced in this point
I want to
um
um under my I want to correct a few
things that have been said here this
morning it says that shark Finning is
happening in the EU the EU has banned
shark filling if it happens it's being
done illegally but it is banned it's
illegal secondly we've been told that uh
shark is not eaten in the EU EU as the
Spain has always eaten sharp so we can't
ban the trade of uh uh shark fins when
we're eating the Sharks themselves so
what can we do and this is where the
commission can come in to look at why
are we not defending band on shop
thinning in rfmos around the world
that's a good mechanism to use secondly
traceability or significance
traceability with the products and then
we'll put an end to the situation let's
work on this let's work on the rfmos but
the European Fleet is working well on
this
thank you very much and now miss Keller
dear colleagues every year thousands of
tons on thin sharks are beautiful
or through the EU because yes the sharks
are being caught at as a whole they're
being landed and then their fins are
being cut off the rest of the shark
bodies being sold off for stuff that not
necessarily everyone wants to eat and
the fins are the stuff that makes the
profit from being exported to Asia and
also many shark fins are going through
the European Union so we clearly have a
problem that is not yet addressed by the
existing and very good legislation we
need to act and we need to act soon
clearly selling shark fins is not about
stopping anyone from starving shark fins
are luxury good and they cause the shark
numbers to decline already now 40 of all
shark species are threatened so we need
to cut the incentive here and in the
Committee hearing with the
representatives of the citizens an
overwhelming majority of colleagues
across the board were supporting this
initiatives unfortunately it seems that
some colleagues didn't take the time
back then to talk with the citizens that
were there so I urge the commission the
commissioner to come forward with a
proposal that honors the more than one
million citizens requests from all
member states thank you
thank you very much next speaker on my
list
Mrs dancing she is not in the room so
for one and a half minutes Mr Milan mon
has
thank you Mr President commissioner as
we all know since 2013 the European
athlete has applied a very a strict
policy to shark Finning however other
fleets around the world do not apply the
same rules it's been already been said
China Korea or Japan are blocking uh the
policy to stop Finning in different
rfmos around the world and a few months
ago the scientist circumference of
parties in Panama
included a number of new species on
certain appendices appendix two now this
means that an international level sharks
and parts of their body can only be
traded in a sustainable manner if they
have a necessary a site certificate
so we need to be clear the EU is not the
problem here our Fleet are meeting the
requirements to ensure sustainable
trading trade of uh Sharps the problem
is the fleece of third countries with
the standards for sustainability which
are much lower if we want to find an
effective solution then we need to focus
our efforts on the activities of third
countries so I would urge for the
European commission as others already
have to redouble their diplomatic
efforts in the necessary rfmos to find
this International Level Playing Field
with for transparency for uh lunding
the trade in shark fins
have a a negative impact on the on the
European Fleet if we do not find
this Level Playing Field okay
she's going to do it in English or in
Spanish
yes thank you very much Mr billerman you
uh say that it's happening outside the
EU that it's happening in Asia and uh
that because it's been banned for a long
time in um you know but but we know that
particularly the Spanish Fleet
these are regularly being captured to
land uh the Finns without them being
attached to sharks with there were two
ships in December that were stopped and
they had they were wanting to land shark
fins so what are you doing in your own
country to really tackle this problem
because it's not enough to just say it's
happening outside Europe
I don't know the cases that you're
referring to but I do have to be clear
on this the European Fleet is well
regular regulated uh they are not
allowed to uh fin sharks and if you know
these cases then uh hopefully uh the
weight of the law will come down on
these two operators but now these are
obviously individual cases where people
could
um
um break the law but we need to what we
need to do is apply the law to those who
are breaking it
next speaker is Mr fulshank for one
minute
thank you today we are discussing a
Prohibition of trade with shark fins we
do that on the background of a Citizens
initiative more than 1.1 million
Europeans signed it filling as it is
called is a brutal practice where sharks
are caught
the fins are cut off and they uh
thereafter after that they are dumped
into the sea
because people are only interested in
their fins which are then sold at a high
price this is cruelty against animals to
the highest degree we cannot accept it
we're happy that thinning is prohibited
in the EU but still a lot of fins are
sold in the European market we have to
stop that and that's why I support a
prohibited provision of trade in shark
fins I'm one of the
people who signed the initiatives some
colleagues say that it doesn't help to
stop the trade but of course it does
the EU is a big market for these fins so
that's why we have to stop the trade
stopping the trade
we can also put an end to this terrible
Praxis thank you
and now miss Miranda for one minute
spinning is a practice which is uh we
can reject and condemn the European
policy says that there's not been
allowed since 2013 as you know
commissioner when this was approved
there were commitments from the European
commission to address uh
um shark Finning around the world as
well no you know commissioner that the
Galician athlete does not practice
thinning but if we look at the
inhibitions around the Galician supply
chain being involved in in Finland then
this is actually except unacceptable
whether it's a blue shark or whether
it's pop Eagles there is no involvement
in this so the the uh Galician Fleet is
only interested in the meat and they
bring the um fish in with fins naturally
attached
[Music]
foreigners in the Galician area have
been
implementing sustainability effort for
many many years now they have the
Fisheries Improvement project which is
an initiative
um overseen by The Fishery progress
project that's ensuring that the fishery
sector is working in such a manner so as
to achieve sustainability along the
supply chain okay thank you very much
and now Mr Caruso for one minute
ladies and gentlemen president the first
time that I heard talk of Finney in it
was in back in 2009 and then it was a
discussion of banning this horrendous
practice and it's now 2023 and citizens
are still fighting to ban it it's tragic
that this didn't happen years ago
Finning threatens many shark species
with Extinction which threatens the
entire Marine ecosystem is a barbaric
violent and unacceptable practice
that is used to feed an illegal Market
from in particular China
there is this pseudo-scientific belief
in the Curative properties of shark fin
soup and still in 2023 we're talking
about this it's Our obligation to ban
this practice and to fight it in
international Arenas so it's banned
everywhere to stop this massacre and we
shouldn't risk as often happens setting
ourselves ground rules but allowing
others not to respect those rules
without paying any price at all stop
Finning now
for one minute
thank you president every year Finning
costs the lives of over 100 million
sharks every year an Ever larger number
of species runs the risk of Extinction
every year this cruel practice robs our
oceans of a predator that is essential
for the health of marine ecosystems
despite the pledges enshrined in the
green deal to protect the marine
environment the EU is still today
responsible for 45 percent of imports of
shark fins by the main Asian markets
so how long will we allow the EU to Aid
in a bet a cruel and unsustainable
practice how long will we betray the
objectives of the green deal we call on
a commission and once and for all to the
trade in shark fins
for one minute
crafts
it is an important question
and the role of the European Union
in this matter is a key
50 percent
of the trade
involves Europe and we're talking about
thousands of tons every year
uh it's a question of the Sharks
themselves but also the ecosystems and
these ecosystems need to be kept in
balance and for that reason it's
extremely important uh that these uh
sharks remain in the ecosystem they're
right at the top of the food chain and
the oceans uh are to act as CO2 sinks
and for that reason we need to maintain
their balance and we need sharks for
that and for me as a green it's uh it
seems strange that we need to talk about
for any in uh 2023 we had a full band
from 2020. now we have finished with the
speakers and we proceed to the catch the
eye there are two requests which will be
accepted Miss kittykinen for one minute
thank you
for creating
confidence
for our citizens in the EU institutions
for 20 years we've been arguing that
disconnecting cutting things should be
stopped
this is the same as so you use Ivory for
instance you take it separate from the
rest of the body and trade in it
poaching illegal trade and literally
green washing
is practiced in products that have been
illegally
fished we cannot have this discipline
here without Banning thinning
nobody needs such Commodities that is
not necessary the question is whether we
do the right thing or are we listening
to
some interest from some lobbying groups
yeah
because if it is no small task and some
considerable achievement to pull off one
of these and it really reflects the
importance of the issue on the one hand
but also how much the EU is involved
being one of the largest shark fin
exporters in the world we know that
since the 1980s the legal shark May
trade has killed around 100 million of
these creatures every year if you count
the illegal and undocumented we could be
talking about
273 million now those figures are
utterly staggering against the backdrop
of 60 percent of shark species being
threatened with Extinction which could
affect obviously the health of our
oceans so I think this is about time
that we do something a bit more decisive
we know that in 2013 you banned the
separation of shark fins and the
disposal at sea but it would be foolish
to think that the regulations don't have
loopholes we know that Spanish vessels
oh the observe on board about one to
three percent of the time examples have
been given in one month alone of two
violations of that so the only way to
deal with it is to stop the trade better
regulate incidental fishing and
strengthen the controlled proceedings so
that we can truly protect diversity in
human health
videos
first of all I'd like to thank you for
today's debate and uh for your comments
and and views on such important topic as
the protection of sharks
and the views expressed by citizens are
crucial when we design and improve our
policies
and the European citizens initiative is
an excellent tool to channel and make
these views here and it's our
institutional and legal obligation to
take them seriously into account
we are now analyzing the initiative very
carefully considering all environmental
economic and social aspects of Possible
full Direction
we are looking in detail at trade
customs and control aspects of shark
fishing which we will all take into
consideration when preparing the reply
to this ECI
now
when it comes to some of the remarks by
some members of the parliament so it's
true
that you legit legislation is very
advanced
and it's true that Asian countries are
the main market for shark fins
and have driven catch and trade of shark
upwards but
the EU is a major player
our share is 15 of cash worldwide
and the reality is that there is a
global problem with sharks and we should
take our responsibilities the EU
position should be geared more and more
at continuing to be part of the solution
rather than becoming part of the problem
or staying silent as an observer
so we are honorable members your
comments questions today have brought to
the discussion also important elements
and perspectives and as I said earlier
the commission will take a decision
on the follow-up to this initiative by
July 2023 and I look forward to
continuing our close cooperation on this
very important topic especially when we
have a strong signal from European
citizens thank you
thank you very much the debased is
closed we would now proceed to the next
item of the agenda in relation to the
Joint debate oceans biodiversity and
Fisheries
the commission statement as regards the
protection
of the ocean systems and
sustainable fish and sustainable
Fisheries
I put one question to the commissioner
that you didn't answer and I would like
to ask him you figure there's been many
comments are made which are incorrect
the European Union I think with its
legislation